we say hello to this man who's going to
the basketball hall of fame uh in short
order uh he'll be a first ballot guy as
we all know uh 13-time all-star
three-time nba champion so on and so
forth but now
there's a book out a memoir that's in
the form as well of some beautiful
photographs from his entire life in his
entire career uh called dwayne right
here on the rich eisen show
mercedes-benz van phone line is dwyane
wade how are you dwane
rich i am doing great thank you for
having me on um i appreciate it man
absolutely it's been a while since uh
since we have connected this book is
beautiful
it's beautiful man congratulations on
that this is this is
this is one that they you know it's
funny you hear the phrase they can never
take it away from you i don't know who's
the one who's ever going to take
anything away from you but
they literally cannot take this away
from you it's beautiful it's great
so congrats thank you matt thank you
richard i appreciate it man we uh we
worked very hard
on this book um you know it's been three
years in the in the making um but uh i'm
i'm so happy with it i'm so happy for
you know what i hope it represents
um you know
it is beautiful as it is gonna look on
someone's coffee table next to all their
fashion magazines that actually um
hopefully can be used
um as a tool and as uh for many you know
and not as a tool of how to live life
but sometimes you just don't you don't
know you don't have the answers
sometimes you need inspiration from
somewhere and hopefully this can be used
as an inspiration for some little kid
you know some some young some grown man
some some woman out there
um anyone so thank you for that so if i
showed this book to the kid from chicago
you know played at uh
harold richards high
right and oak lawn and said this here's
this book this is your life which one
would have blown you away the most
looking through it
which one would have blown you away the
most that that photograph exists
besides everything that's right i mean
i i
listen i i think the thing is is like
you know i think now people know me as
dwyane wade the accomplished athlete
and everything that i've done but
the young kid that looks at that will
look at these photos
he couldn't have imagined this because
he didn't see it you know and so it
would have seemed like a fairy tale in a
sense because
i just never i never i never imagined
none of this you know i i wanted to play
the game of basketball of course but i
didn't know
what all came with that i didn't know
that i would have an opportunity to
become more than a basketball player i
didn't know so
i think that kid would just be looking
at it like it's just
it's a it's a book of art that's fairy
tale to him you know no doubt about it i
mean i'm looking through it i see the
photographs of you obviously with lebron
and kobe poor anderson varajal there's a
two-page spread on you dunking on him um
you know
wherever he is right now i feel for him
as he's thumbing through this thing um
you know and then obviously your your
championship years your your beautiful
family so uh when when you look back on
all of this which which moment do you
think is the one that you want people to
know about
for you dwayne now this current guy you
watching this book yeah i mean that you
know that that's obviously that's that's
always hard man we you know my my
photographer bob and tell us um and i
had to you know really take
from almost over a million pictures that
we have and we had to yeah they take it
down to 200 photos and so damn to me
obviously every one of these photos
speaks right and so
i you know rich to me this goes back to
when i was a kid i remember
getting michael jordan's uh rare error
book
and and i remember just like being able
to see things about my favorite player
that i've never been able to see before
right like i
honestly i i wasn't in the locker room
so i never seen michael jordan toes
and i actually seen him on the cover on
the book and i was like michael jordan
half coins it made me feel better about
myself
you know i mean and so like for me to be
able to put this book together after you
know my nba career
and and after you know 39 years of life
um to hopefully become that image for
you know the little dwayne you know of
the world just like mj became an image
for me you know seeing him play with his
kids and all the things that was like
dang jordan is human
that to me is hope what i what i hope
you know this book you know kind of
shows that hopefully shows the human
side of someone that everyone has gotten
the chance to know through sport and of
course you won championships with a guy
who's most associated uh with jordan's
career in argument form like who's this
who's the you know lebron versus jordan
and things like that uh he's human too
uh give me a story about lebron that
folks
don't know
you know because we only see i don't
think he will want me to give a story
about him that people don't know is that
right oh that's called that's called
broke hole right but i think the thing
is
you know with having the opportunity you
know just like the players that had an
opportunity to play with kareem and
wilt and magic and bird
you know all these great players
obviously mj and so forth and so on to
be able to have the opportunity to be
able to witness
um this guy's greatness you know and and
i always say like the world gets to
witness it at you know
most nights around you know when he
played with me around 7 30.
uh but i got a chance to witness it and
practice every day i got a chance to
witness it in uh in in the weight room i
got a chance to witness it when it came
to how we take care take care of his
body his family his people
just everything man what this guy stands
for i mean it's it's no secret of the
six you know it's no mistake
of the success that he's been able to
have
um because of you know wanting the
people around him um but you know the
way that he he cares about it all and
you know he handles it gracefully and he
ends it very well what about what people
say about him does he really does he
care about that sort of thing you know
because the word sensitive is frequently
associated with
lebron and there's everyone's got an
opinion about him whether it's in any
arena sports politics pop culture what
about that dwayne anything you could
speak to about that well
yeah rich you show me somebody who don't
care what people say about them and i'm
gonna show you someone who's lying
we all care
we you know we all care about what
people say about us it just may be in
different fields you know i think people
expect because he's so great that he
should not care but
we do care you know and that's just who
we are as human beings a man has a post
he's not
he's not a robot he may look like it
but he's actually human and you do care
not now it that doesn't mean that he's
gonna allow it to affect him he's gonna
stop playing a game of basketball
because you don't like something about
the way he plays the game but
you know it's okay that we're in a
generation right now that athletes are
able to express their you know their
dislike for comments that people are
saying to them you know like athletes
are not coming to anyone's job saying
hey you suck at your job you suck as a
journalist you suck as a newspaper guy
not we're not you know
you're not doing that and so
we get exactly you get people telling
you every day what they don't like about
you know what you do and you put your
all into what you do and you're better
than you're a hundred thousand times
better than anybody who comment on your
basketball talent so if he wants to be
sensitive it's his art it's his it's his
journey let him be sensitive about it
dwyane wade here on the rich eisen show
again his new book is memoir with 200
photographs that i'm sure was one of the
most painstaking processes to choose
dwayne wade here on the rich eisen show
you've met uh just flipping through this
book it confirms what everyone assumes
uh you've had an incredible life so far
and you've gotten to meet so many cool
people but in terms of the coolest i
can't imagine anybody's above pat riley
uh you got a good good you got a good
pat riley story for me dwyane wade where
you're like this is this is in fact one
of the coolest individuals in the
history of cool and individuals you got
a good one for me
on that front man dwyane wade uh you
know what rich
you may be the first person to ask me
that question about a cool pat raleigh
story i i think president obama might be
cooler than pat but okay
all right by the way by the way that's a
that's a that's a great uh you know
upgrade i understand that but
you know pat i mean
chris bosh on the show and he said that
he put his his his championship rings uh
in front of him and said you know this
is what you get when you get here and he
gave him one
um by the way i have to say dwayne
chris told me that story on the show
um that he took out like some sort of
like crown royal looking bag and had all
these championship rings in it and gave
him one of the rings and then he still
he told me he still had it i said you
know what be a good time to give it back
to him is during your hall of fame
speech he says not a bad idea then did
it
so i'm gonna take credit for that
um you know i try to make
so uh that's also my way of tap dancing
long enough for you to maybe think of a
good pat riley story for me well you
know what i agree i appreciate that sure
great that's great uh you're great at
what you do thank you dwayne i
appreciate you saying that
you are because i was sitting here the
whole time listening but also thinking
of it
i don't know
right i don't know if i can top i don't
know if i could top chris bot i mean
that was
that was amazing i mean watching chris
give him back there though it was so
dramatic and so for movies and i loved
every minute of it because i'm dramatic
um
but you know i think the thing is for me
you know like i
i getting drafted
by miami and getting drafted by pat
um to me you know i just i had so much
pride in it man you know it's like i
know who he coached i know who he is
and he trusted me to be the the one to
kind of take this franchise to a
different you know place and so
i just think pat is you know i think he
is what we all think you know he's just
a cool
like away from the game of basketball i
got a chance to vacation with pat you
guys have seen some video like pat has
taught me how to do a couple dance moves
like i've seen pat with the mask off you
know and i've seen a sensitive side and
a different side of pat that most people
don't get to see and so it's kind of fun
he actually is kind of fun don't i mean
my gosh the man's been there and done
all that and uh just you know seeing him
sitting there in his silver hair what
you know and that soon to be former
staples center now crypto.com arena uh
this past week watching the heat go
against both la teams it was pretty cool
to just see him there i would be remiss
if i did not ask you one current
basketball question dwyane wade before i
let you go and i know you're you're in
management now so i can you put in
perspective what uh steph curry's doing
now uh entering his mid-30s and
performing at this level
that looks like you know he's uh he's
still in the ncaa tournament you know
it's amazing what what he's doing right
now
dwayne what about from your perspective
about steph yeah i got uh
i guess four words um
mount rushmore make room
you know i feel that
steph curry
should not be out of the conversation to
join that mount rushmore you know he's
what he's proven to do not only what
he's done but what he did last year and
what he's come back to do this year
i don't see no slowing down in steph
curry and so we don't see those slowing
down at steph curry we don't have to
have a different conversation
um about what that mount rushmore could
possibly look like one day i mean he's
he's changed the game in a way um that
you know has taken us into this
to the place where it makes sense when
you hear that the stable sentence is
gonna well not make sense to the la fans
but make sense when you hear crypto you
know uh dot com is gonna be the name
like we're in a different
world right now we're in a different you
know air and steph curry is in a
different area he's taking us here he's
taking a game of basketball here and
even though everybody out there is
trying to be like steph curry
no one is coming close to being like
steph curry still and so man i just i'm
i'm just loving that i'm a fan at this
time and i'm able to sit back and watch
this man's greatness um because it's
just it's it's beautiful it's like
watching mj as a kid you know and i'm
not saying he's mj but just how
beautifully michael jordan played the
game of basketball steph curry do it he
just don't do it in the air you do it on
the ground
i guess as long as he doesn't do it
against the jazz pretty much right
yeah well yeah you i we wanted to hit 10
threes you know try to limit them to
about five sure uh
i'm just trying to figure that one out
right there hey duane thanks for the
time i know you're you're uh you gotta
run i'd love to do this more often when
you're not just selling a a book um i
always appreciate our chats and
everybody should go get uh dwayne which
is this beautiful coffee table book as
you pointed out with uh with your life
inside it stories and pictures congrats
on this and let's do this again soon
appreciate it thank you rich man always
appreciate it right back at you that's
it that's dwayne wayne thank you that's
dwyane wade twitter and instagram at
dwyane wade right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here